find the inverse of each function f of x  2x minus 1 3 minus 4X cubed and 6X  divided by 7x minus 4.  there's a four-step procedure to work  out these problems replace f of x with y  then swap X and Y in each equation  this is straightforward in the first two  equations in the last equation you need  to replace two of the X's with two of  the Y's  finally solve for y in each of the  equations  straightforward for the first two  equations  in the last equation we just have to be  careful we want to bring all the Y terms  to one side then factor and then divide  through  finally replace y with f inverse of X so  the inverses are X Plus 1 all over two  the cube root of 3 minus X all over four  and four x divided by 7x minus 6.